One way to think about this problem is the inverse. Which of these processes
normally is done by a programmable shader? The illumination model is evaluated
at the vertex or shader level. Similarly, the vertex shader performs model view
transforms as well as perspective, though not the perspective divide. The
Z-buffer is hardwired in. As this is a speed critical piece that is used by
most 3D applications. It's evaluated outside of the fragment shader. Image
post-processing, such as color correction and so on, is something that can be
done in the fragment shader. Typically by rendering a full screen quadrilateral
to drive the computations. Rasterization happens in between vertex and fragment
shading, so it's performed by dedicated hardware. It's what generates the
fragments for the fragment shader to process. Clipping is also hardwired and
happens just after the vertex shader and before rasterization itself. The
vertex shader outputs vertex locations and clipping space for this hardware to
process.